Die perfekte Mango reift nicht am Baum
und lagert viele Wochen auf einem Schiff.
Wie die Industrie mit moderner
Technologie süße Mangos in die
Supermärkte liefert, zeigt euch Sebastian
Lege.
Ich war heute in Köln Mangos einkaufen. Rewe Bio, Rewe, Edeka, Lidl, Aldi.
Was meinen Sie, welche von diesen Mangos
ist die süßeste?
Sebastian macht den Test und zwar nach wissenschaftlichen
Kriterien. Mithilfe eines kleinen Geräts
misst er den sogenannten Brix-Wert. Der
gibt an, wie viel Zucker im Fruchtsaft
steckt. Je höher der Brix-Wert, desto
reifer die Mango.
Wow, 13,9. Die Mango ist schon mal reif,
die Rewe Bio.
Der Zuckergehalt hängt natürlich auch
von der Sorte ab.
Ab 12 Brix aber schmeckt einfach jede
Mango.
Ist richtig süß und lecker.
Schon ein paar Messungen später zeigen sich
drastische Unterschiede.
Die Mango von Edeka hat nur einen Brix-
Wert von 10,3.
Das ist zwar reif, heißt aber weniger Zucker.
Die Technik hat recht,
geschmacklich haut die mich nicht um.
Die Stichprobe zeigt, die Süße der Mangos
unterscheidet sich deutlich von Markt zu
Markt. In Leges Reifeprüfung gewinnen am
Ende die Mangos von Lidl,
sie haben einen Brix-Wert von über 19
und damit den höchsten Zuckergehalt.
Aber wie kommen die Unterschiede
zustande?
Mangos werden hierzulande immer
beliebter. Rund 50.000 Tonnen kaufen wir
jährlich, die meisten aus Lateinamerika.
Hier werden die Früchte geerntet, aber
nicht reif, sondern grün. Nur so lassen
sie sich transportieren ohne dabei zu
verderben,
denn die Schiffsreise nach Deutschland
dauert bis zu drei Wochen. Wenn die
Früchte dann hier ankommen, sind sie
immer noch hart und sauer. Die Industrie
löst das Problem mit Technik und Chemie.
Mithilfe solcher Anlagen kann sie die
Süße der Früchte programmieren.
Reifemeister Thorsten Reno erklärt, wie es
geht.
Mango gibt es ja eigentlich schon immer, früher waren sie
halt ziemlich teuer, weil man die Ware hierher geflogen hat. Aus der ganzen
Sache wollten wir halt raus, dafür haben
wir die Reifekammern gebaut.
Fast 32.000 Mangos passen in eine Kammer. Ein
Spezialgas sorgt dafür, dass die grünen
Mangos gleichzeitig reif werden - auf den
Punkt genau.
Dazu versiegelt Thorsten Reno das Tor
der Reifekammer und zieht die Luft aus
dem Raum. Über Düsen in der Wand strömt
das Reifegasgemisch in die Kammer.
96% Stickstoff und 4% Ethylen. Für Menschen lebensgefährlich, für
Mangos dagegen optimal zum süß werden.
Im Durchschnitt verbringen die Früchte
4 bis 8 Tage in der Kammer, in der
Natur brauchen sie bis zur Reife rund
10 Tage und sind abhängig vom Wetter.
Schiffstransport und Reifekammer sparen
somit Zeit und Geld. Das nützt auch der
Umwelt, denn beim Transport wird CO2
eingespart.
Zum Vergleich: Werden die Mangos in
Deutschland gereift, reisen sie langsam
per Schiff mit einer CO2-Bilanz von 0,8
Kilogramm je Kilo Früchte. Reifen die
Mangos dagegen vor Ort müssen sie
eingeflogen werden, das setzt ganze 14,6
Kilo CO2 frei. Bevor die Früchte aus der
Kammer in den Handel kommen, wird ihre
Reife geprüft. Dazu messen die Techniker
den Brix-Wert der Früchte mit dem
gleichen Gerät wie auch Sebastian Lege
in seiner Werkstatt.
Der Brix ist so weit fortgeschritten,
dass wir damit arbeiten können, mit der
Ware. Reifeprüfung bestanden.
Der Großteil der Stärke im Inneren der
Früchte hat sich in Zucker umgewandelt,
die Mangos sind reif.
Lecker!
Sichtbarer Nachteil der Reifekammer: Selbst bei süßen
Früchten bleibt die Schale grün, weil sie
keine Sonne abbekommen hat.
Eine grüne Mango sieht unreif aus,
aber kann genauso geschmacklich sehr gut sein
wie eine Rote oder auch eine Gelbe.
Der Inhalt, der drin ist, ist das
Ausschlaggebende.
Aber wie soll man dann erkennen ob eine
Mango wirklich reif ist, ohne sie
aufzuschneiden?
Die Industrie setzt dabei auf Hightech-Maschinen. Blitzschnell erfassen sie für
jede einzelne Mango verschiedene
Qualitätsmerkmale.
Per Laser werden unreife Früchte erkannt.
Ein Resonanzmesser prüft die Festigkeit.
Und am Ende kontrolliert eine Fotobox
die Schale auf Flecken und Risse.
Ist die Mango noch nicht reif, wird sie
aussortiert und muss noch einmal zurück
in die Reifekammer.
Der Rest wird abgepackt und in diesem
Fall für den Verkauf im deutschen Bio-Handel fertig gemacht.
Bleibt nur die Frage: Wenn sich die
Früchte so perfekt reifen lassen, warum
stoßen wir Verbraucher im Handel dann
auf unterschiedlich reife Mangos?
Das hat auch etwas mit unserem Einkaufsverhalten
zu tun.
In Märkten, in denen die Mangos schnell
über die Ladentheke gehen, werden Kunden
eher vollreife Früchte angeboten. Greift
die Kundschaft zögerlich zu, ordern die
Märkte lieber weniger reife Mangos, denn
die verderben nicht, sondern reifen noch
nach. Jetzt ein kleiner Tipp von mir:
Bevor sie die nächste Mango kaufen,
an dem kleinen Stielende mal nach vorn
und hinten bewegen. Wenn er sich leicht
bewegen lässt, wissen wir schon mal, die
Mango ist reif.
Guten Appetit!
Übrigens, nicht nur Mangos
werden in Reifekammern behandelt.
Eingeführt wurde das Ethylenverfahren
ursprünglich für Bananen.
Heute werden auch Avocados und Papayas
zum Großteil in Reifekammern behandelt.
So landen exotische Früchte das ganze
Jahr über reif bei uns in den
Supermärkten und Discountern. Ein
cleverer Trick!
Wo kauft ihr die leckersten Mangos? Oder greift ihr sogar zur Flugware? Sagt
es uns in den Kommentaren!
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über eure
Lebensmittel wissen wollt, schaut in die
nächsten zwei Clips und abonniert die
ZDFbesseresser!